did you see colin kaepernick's show that
he did on netflix i heard about it
he does this kind of like
yeah critique
you know that
carlton and urkel
are these like white washed black
characters yeah it's kind of like
[Music]
just like all negative the way at least
he's approaching it did you have a
reaction to that or do people
um
i think he's just concerned about being
famous at this point
so you know i don't really say other
people's names i don't let other
people's names come out of my mouth
unless i
do have a extreme personal beef with
them sure so that list is extremely
short sure um um if i do say somebody
else's name i generally want to say
something positive to dig up them so
when somebody and i met him before
actually
so and it was a totally cool meeting you
know um
dapped up photo benefit photo's still on
my instagram i was like i don't need to
go back and highlight it now though so
when somebody does that it's just more
or less like
i think it was kind of like dialogue
maybe that was stuck in his mouth i
wonder and i mean
i'm pretty sure he didn't even write it
probably i'm sorry i'm pretty sure you
didn't even write it
um it was really just dialogue stuck in
his mouth and when your primary concern
is just being famous at this point
then you're not thinking about who else
you're affecting with with those with
those words you know what i'm saying but
you got to kind of just take it with a
game you know great assault i'm not even
familiar with the uh the whole thing but
it sounds
sounds [ __ ] up too it was sort of just
like
i did like the show but that was one of
the few things i was like that was like
aggressive and kind of not not really
fair you know it was just it was it was
a little too academic for him it was
like hey bro you're not that deep
right right like yeah if you want to be
a college professor and go ahead and
support that with you know 10 more
minutes uh go ahead and do that but
that's
your backup quarterback yeah yeah don't
do that uh-huh yeah it lacked a lot of
nuance and yeah it just felt right
so it was like but at the same time i
was like i'm not trying to start a beef
even right there sure now it's like you
know
there's degrees to understand so you're
you're a vet so there's degrees to
understanding in this business
you know just simple sound bites what
directions they can take you you know
what i'm saying and that's why i was
like you would i would just i would hope
that he
understands hey man when you mention
somebody else's name of fame in this
town
it should be in a positive manner
otherwise the clickbait people are gonna
do what they do and they made sure i saw
it after my morning donut
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]